what's up reject nation my name is John
Humphrey and with me is Tony Gael Tony
Gill you can check them out on twitch
today we're together we're going to
check out this new Rick and Morty season
3 trailer I am a big fan of Rick and
Morty as you can tell Tony yeah
absolutely seen all the episodes
I like to re-watch the show before you
know the new season comes out of seen
anything that is the first episode new
season yeah oh okay yeah so we're on the
same page let's check this out no
further ado here we go all right Morty
are you invisible and you're gonna like
fart on me put the pickle over I turned
myself into a pickle Marty a pickle
[Applause]
[Music]
Sorry Sorry
[Music]
[Music]
look at me turkey gear market
[Music]
differently please okay but nothing did
you told me cue indicator it used to
answer a literal call to adventure
morning let it go to voicemail
[Music]
normal everything okay here only show
this smart could be this stupid welcome
all new episodes begin Sunday July 30th
at 11:30 take more than that to kill
record morning this like newest run free
only on the don't swim oh man hell yeah
alright alright yeah alright I mean
that's a pretty sweet trailer I mean
it's you know just sort of a glorified
medley of clips but if I had an
equivalent of nipple chills I would be
mine would be more excitement based and
that made me very excited how do you
feel sir with this show and I just I
just never know when I'm going to expect
as like the second season when it right
when does about to come out first thing
I thought was like how are they going to
top their first seat like they're so
first things it was so good and right
off the first episode you're like wow
this is great can't wait for the next
episode every episode hit delivered for
me even the first episode that we got
for this next season I showed a couple
of clips of it I thought it was going to
be April Fool's joke but ended up being
like a full-on video yeah yeah more like
that April Fool's gift yeah more of a
gift you need you need to guess way more
than not the fools a nice change oh you
know cuz April Fool's is kind of a
cumbersome death well y'all I think any
time I think of any cartoon show messing
with us on April Fool's South Park they
did it so many times so well that's like
the official day of like announcing that
stuff that you really want is here again
and I'm how yeah yeah I mean this
governor likes I granted like you know
it is just again like a big medley of
images I like this show on multiple
levels - so this mostly sells the
adventure to me and he keeps repeating
that thing like this is the darkest year
of our adventures and at least you know
looking at the first episode of season 3
and then some of these
I mean it definitely looks like they're
continuing to go full-bore with the
sci-fi full-bore with the creatures and
the absurdity in the action and that's
what I love across-the-board about Rick
and Morty you know I think they're their
slogan is kind of perfect like only a
show this smart could be dis doing a
glamour fix logo right there for that
part it's like real sci-fi but with a
whacked-out you know crazy packaging
well I mean like right when you first
watch the first episode of brick and
where you go like oh this is crazy
psycho but you can never take it serious
because he's constantly going to be
burping and just like interrupting with
like the rudest shitty could possibly
say so when I first watch these shows
like all through I never thought about
like all the hidden messages a little
like little meanings are like even old
school shows that they put into the show
until like Yuri wash and rewatching and
even adding things online that you know
fan theories go crazy it's going to just
really rewatch value oh definitely just
to see like all the like even in the
trailer you see that they did like matt
has a hurry when I saw that I was like
oh man I can't wait to see like their
parody of what they're gonna do for Mad
Max and yeah I love the purge episode
like it was just so great how they had
their own version of the purge and it
wasn't even actual people a little cat
people so you just never felt like it
was just like going off Oh Massa Cary
but even so I mean that what a part of
what I appreciate about about this show
in episode like that especially is when
the show takes the time to allow it to
actually get real them because it gives
like the way that whole episode ends up
with like Morty really trying to be
above it all and then giving in and kind
of snapping and stuff like that I think
that's the thing I love most about this
show is that you have the cool side line
you have the zany antics and then the
wacky lines the level of a dub-dub
but you can have emotional huh yeah and
I wasn't expecting this to have him but
like when I watched that episode where
Morty gets to shoot the adventure mm-hmm
a rape like when he wasn't about like
cringing feelings like oh my god what's
about to happen and then like yeah you
kind of forget that he dances just a
cart like a silly cartoon and then all
of a sudden you're like wow he's great
right now you're doing that like so yeah
like you experienced early
you experience a lot of different
emotions when I watch definitely
episodes of Rick and Morty and that's
you know nowadays that's that's what
excites me and that's what draws me to
show like that or I kind of put it in a
in a similar category even though the
tones are different with stuff like
Bojack horseman even the tones a bit
different you know you have the zany
comedy and then the strange antics and
the you know the absurd freedoms but
they also take the time to really
develop the character and then Rick and
Morty has both the cereal and an
episodic quality and you know you we
ended up season tuna in a pretty tense
little cliffhanger you know emotional
cliffhanger yeah um and so that's that's
what makes this show so special to me
and I've heard some of the recent you
know news reports and stuff about why is
it taking so long are they fighting or
whatever dan harmon came on pretty much
said like we just we've just been taking
way too long to write and we've been
thinking kind of really hard about this
and sometimes you think too hard then
you come back around to you know your
original ideas and and blah blah blah
hopefully that doesn't spell trouble you
know I feel like they still have a good
enough grip to make this show good and I
saw some of the live event on YouTube
they did yesterday and you know it
looked like the crew you know was
getting along real good and everything
so I just can't wait for this like what
show like this I I'm one of those people
that even though it will take a long
time I know will I just know that that
it's going to make it that much better
each episode and I I'm willing to wait
like you get little things like when
they did the the rick roll remember when
they edited all the clips together where
rick roll us and then i give you up just
here and there to give you a little like
a little something-something just so you
you don't like you're just so
anticipated you just want more and more
rick marty but just for them to give us
the one episode and just be like we have
the show coming here's an episode and
that episode killed it here was like
fruit it was exactly what you would hope
like a seasoned starter episode be like
yeah they create a whole mean just right
off the bat sex once a day that's one
day i want that bad people sold that for
thousands of dollars on evening that was
a great episode and just like the kick
started to be like
we're coming back Nuria become very
strong with this first episode so oh it
season look amazing I can't wait to
watch this episode over and over again
waiting to hear all the theories people
come up with with like did you see this
part can see this little like hidden
clue that they put from this show or
everything that are its own ready to let
go as a visually and an even dialogue
dense show you know all right boys and
girls thank you for checking out this
video are you saying excited for Rick
and Rory season 3 hit us up in the
comments let us know your thoughts what
you're looking forward to as always you
can subscribe to the real rejects by
clicking that subscribe button hit that
notification bell get notified every
time the video is out make sure also to
follow us on TV time you know I'm going
to be writing up episodes when the show
starts to air you can find my man Tony
guilt on twitch what's your Twitter name
you is in the gamer it's in the gamer
what's in the gamer it in use what is it
idiot what are you just what it is a
game son